right now the cardinals missing 60
of their starting rotation so this turns
out to be a very important start for
adam wainwright trying to
change the fortunes of the saint louis
cardinals this year six plus innings per
start and in today's game that's not bad
i mean it really isn't cesar hernandez
will lead it off
and he lines one down the right field on
it to base it he's on his way to second
base he's going for a double and he'll
go in standing with a two beggar just
over the glove of the big man paul
goldschmidt at first base and it might
have kicked up a little painted chalk
ahmed rosario
three for five last night right back up
the middle softly served ah that's nice
and it's gonna be an infield hit but
hernandez never left second base that's
a bad base of base running right there
but now runners at the corners then
here's eddie rosario rosario rips one to
right down the line it goes fair ball
ricochets into the corner hernandez
scores rosario stopped at third and the
other rosario stops at second and andy
rosario with a ringing rbi double into
the right field corner and the indians
have jumped on adam wainwright for a
one-nothing lead
sarbaugh says don't you stay right here
still only one out big harold at the
plate
in the air center field that'll get it
done carlson makes the catch
ahmed rosario tags and scores it's two
to nothing give big harold his 14th run
driven in on the year well the indians
able to put two more on the board in the
first inning like they did for bieber
last night tonight it'll be jc mejia
making his second start and he's been
very good in his first eight innings
this guy has a power sinker he mixes in
a little slider and a change up look for
a lot of ground balls if he's on his
game here's tommy edmond
a base hit into right center
that will roll all the way to the track
sliding zimmer
to make sure it didn't get to the wall
and that keeps edmond at second instead
of third nice play in center lead off
double tommy edmonds runners at first
and second tyler o'neal is reach base
safely in 15 straight slowly hit
no chance to get him bases loaded for
the cardinals in field hit tyler o'neal
bases loaded two outs the return of
yachty to the lineup tonight 3-2
and he walked him wanted it back 10
pitch hit back by yada yada molina
cardinals get on the board that scores
tommy edmond in a 2-1 game here in the
bottom of the first the reaction to yada
yada he knew that was a good at-bat he
worked for that rbi the bases are loaded
for carpenter the shift on the right
side his last six starts hitting 400
with four doubles 2-2 pitch
carpenter lines it bare
inside the right field line all the way
down into the corner two runs have
scored here comes yachty carpenter
clears the bases
on his way to third with heads up base
running saint louis on top
you talked about tension before that
pitch
this relieves some tension from matt
carpenter number one but also from his
manager and maybe from some cardinal
fans too
who've been waiting for a first inning
like this
outstanding at bat for carpenter and you
could say that about molina and then
tyler o'neil just a terrific answer for
the cardinals in the bottom of the first
by scoring those four four runs ricky
it's a chance for adam wainwright to
kind of regroup after that first inning
it's a new game love the run support
don't you you bet hanging breaking ball
o'neal diving forward and comes up with
it
laid out comes up with a great catch and
left tyler o'neill
well you know tyler o'neil's going to
give up his body and do whatever it
takes i mean he's had a really good
defensive last couple of weeks here's
anna wainwright he's a good hitting
pitcher phil mayton got the last out in
the first
second and he's down swinging one away
the 2-2
got him looking back door curve and so
may town has struck all all three
cardinals here's the two two
checked and took a fastball strike three
maintain strikes out the side and he's
keeping the indians in this game tough
to pitch any better than phil maton has
since coming into the game in relief he
has been lights out mayton has struck
out all five cardinals he's faced nolan
aronado right-hander against
right-hander
and oronato hits it down into the
left-field corner and a fair ball
hops over the sidewall
and so that'll be a ground rule double
tail o'neill infield hit run scored back
in the first inning he's now reached
base safely and 16 straight the 01 pitch
oh deal crushes one out to deep left
field how far
mammoth shot
tyler o'neill
home run number 14. two-run homer
over the bullpen and left tyler o'neal
with home run number 14
and he's driven in 31. i thought that
was a nice smooth swing it was a good
finish by tyler o'neill 7 8 and 9 for
cleveland the 2-2
put in play and him to reach again
arenato
cutting that ball off before it got to
sosa ranging to his left for the out 12
in a row here's owen miller the pinch
hitter so again terry francona will go
back to his pen
swaying and a mess
good battle there and he strikes out the
pinch hitter miller that's four tonight
for adam wainwright that's out number
one runners first and second top of the
order and tommy edmund batting
left-handed one for three with a double
nice play by naylor uh chance for double
play but not quite in time there two
down quantro is ready the pitch
swung out and a rocket to deep right but
right there to snag it as ramirez
cuantro able to get out of it got him
wainwright having one of those stopper
moments here and hoping that he would
and then give way to the hot guys in the
bullpen who are well rested and we may
see one or two of them but i think waeda
wants to go as far as he can strikeout
number six adam wainwright
they needed this tonight and they're
getting it there's goldschmidt it's been
hit by a pitch over two with a pair of
strikeouts
and the 01 is hit out to deep right
field ramirez is back gone just over the
wall at an opposite field home run
paul goldsmith eighth home run for
goldie and he's driven in 30 on the year
just over the wall in right now tyler
o'neal blasted a two-run homer in the
third
and o'neal sends one out to center
zimmer back at the wall god
two home run night tyler o'neill
he's got 15 bombs this year his home run
trot is faster than guys that are going
for an inside the park homer
well it never gets old for him that's
for sure so he earned that pitch
and then he does this second big fly of
the game
the ball just carries
eddie rosario the final hope for
cleveland in this 8-2 game the 2-2
and a high-fly ball into center field
this should do it the losing streak will
come to a close and cardinal pitching
retires
26 of the final 27 indians what a night
for cardinal pitching
and a nice way to break the losing skid